Fixed up
but different
stitches
skin grafts scar tissue
72 days bedridden the outside is healing
but the inside it's like suddenly i can
see through walls
through lies like the smiles they use to
hide their pity and fear
they see me as a victim a failure a
thing that could happen to them
and they're right the truth hurts more
than the 27 shattered bones joker gave
me
but what i see is that they're the
victims
victims of bruce wayne
adopted codependent of his mommy daddy
issues
barbara crippled by a maniac of his
creation
what kind of damaged individual mentors
a child into the line of fire to begin
with
the butler did it i was doing fine
before bruce brought me into his family
i was alone before this family i was
alive before i let this insanely messed
up family lead me to slaughter
never again no more family
I alone will become more than the dreams
and nightmares they imagined for me
we save lives every day strangers
and there's always enough time
but i failed to save jason from this
life
joker got a hold of stolen uranium he's
selling it to terrorists
it's gonna take batman and robin
together to close this case
you take them down while i investigate
that warehouse we track joker to
please tell the big man i said hello
i alone will become more than the dreams
and nightmares they imagined for me
the red hood's knowledge of my tactics
my history
this was getting personal
joker showed me the truth evil can't be
cured
only killed
life or death
Because of my choice i had to avoid repeating mistakes
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie they
just dropped a new trailer for batman
and death in the family the red hood
movie that they're releasing later this
year actually just in a couple weeks
they've changed a bunch of things and
reincorporated the classic
red hood movie so we'll explain what's
going on if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll do an amazon giveaway for copies
of the movie all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and let me know what
your favorite red hood
story is most of you will probably say
under the red hood just because it's one
of the most iconic batman stories
still hoping for a live action under the
red hood movie at some point there's so
many different batman live action movies
that are coming in the next couple years
between the justice league snyder cut
the robert pattinson batman movie
trilogy we also have a version of a dead
robin
inside zack snyder's batman v superman
and obviously justice league the snyder
cut
i don't know what they're going to be
doing with that during the snyder cut if
there'll be any references to it
but the way zack snyder explained it
after batman v superman was that was
actually supposed to be the grayson
robin not the jason todd robin so had
they done
a live-action version of batman under
the red hood with ben affleck's batman
it would have been a very different
version of that story maybe we'll get an
under the red hood movie at some point
but what they've done is they've tried
to create an interactive choose your own
adventure style movie with
under the red hood using batman to death
in the family
a death in the family is just the
prequel to under the red hood as most of
you will know
they told some of that story at the
beginning of the under the red hood
movie you remember jensen ackles played
red hood during that is pretty iconic
a while ago he even dressed up as red
hood for halloween doing some really
crazy cosplay so it does sound like he
wants to do some batman stuff in live
action
if you've been watching the boys tv show
on amazon it's a great parody series of
a dark version of the justice league in
the dc universe and marvel's avengers
over in the mcu
but if you didn't hear the news jensen
ackles is actually going to be starring
during the boys season 3 as a version of
their in-universe captain america he's
called soldier boy on the show but he's
basically a version of captain america
but the reason why they're releasing
this movie now is because this year it's
the anniversary of the batman under the
red hood movie
the funny thing about the whole choose
your own adventure aspect of the movie
is that it itself is a big easter egg
call back to the original fate of jason
todd in the comic book death in the
family story
where dc did the phone in campaign
allowing readers to vote on what would
happen to jason todd
would he live or would he die at the
hands of the joker at the time dc
editorial had felt like jason todd as a
character just wasn't as popular and was
thinking about going in a different
direction
but they were giving the fans the
readers the opportunity to keep jason
todd robin around in the dc universe
obviously you can guess what the results
of that contest were but later it was
actually claimed that people had found a
way to spam the phone results and cheat
the contest
the number of votes for killing him were
just a little bit more
than the votes for saving him so had the
results not been cheated had it been
more legit
it's possible that jason todd would not
have been killed in that infamous story
but it's one of the biggest moments in
batman's history so it's crazy to think
that it would have gone down that other
way
r.i.p jason todd it was hardcore i still
remember seeing that for the first time
they didn't pull any punches with that
either joker not only killed jason todd
he tortured him for a good long while
before the bomb went off
it was just meant to be this impossible
scenario just this impossible choice for
batman and his failure to save jason
todd was supposed to
break him as a character for a while or
at least until dc introduced the tim
drake robin
which funny enough didn't take that long
but that's just the way that publishing
works
so it sounds like this batman movie will
tell most of that story in flashbacks
because you see a lot of jason todd red
hood
in this costume with this version of the
robin costume of the bandages in present
day a lot
they did the same thing with batman
flashbacks during the under the red hood
movie where batman flashes back and
remembers jason todd
as a child when he became robin for the
first time like he remembers meeting him
for the first time when he caught him
trying to steal the wheels right off of
the batmobile and for those of you
hoping for more hardcore
r-rated dc movies this is actually going
to be a rated r animated movie
they've actually been doing that more
often with a couple of their more recent
animated movies like justice league
apocalypse war their big universe
ending or universe rebooting dc movie
was a rated r
movie batman the killing joke also
erated our movie
kind of divisive people weren't quite as
happy with the creative on that movie
but obviously it's a crazy batman story
that
demands to be done in a rated r fashion
they're actually releasing the movie
through their dc showcase brand if you
guys don't remember that they actually
did that a long time ago for their
shorter movies a good example of that is
the superman shazam versus black adam
movie from a couple years ago
obviously that was long before they were
going to do the rox version of black
adam in the live action movies
i've already done a black adam trailer
video and funny enough he keeps hyping
up
black adam versus superman so even
though the plot of the movie is going to
be very different from the animated
superman shazam versus black adam movie
we might see some easter eggs for things
like that happening in the black adam
movie
if you're a big red hood fan you're
hoping for some sort of hbo
dc red hood series the thing that they
just announced is that all the dc
universe shows are coming to hbo max
that includes titan season 3
and during that they are doing jason
todd red hood
they didn't say exactly how they're
going to do it but he will become
red hood during season three i believe
they're also going to be featuring a
version of batgirl during that i don't
know if it's going to be in flashbacks i
don't know exactly how they're going to
accomplish their barbara gordon
or how old she's going to be but we'll
find out more about that sometime next
year
just because everything is slowly
getting started because of the virus
delays
the minute that they cast jason todd for
titans everyone was just posting all the
red hood memes like r.i.p jason todd
everybody was just expecting him to die
sooner rather than later so that they
could do their red hood story there were
a couple moments during season two where
it seemed like they were going to do that
but then they'd pull back at the last
second and he'd wind up surviving
it just sounds like whatever's going to
happen with that during season 3
he will seemingly quote unquote either
die or become red hood in some other
fashion
hopefully if they have to change the
story line they won't change it too much
they haven't quite introduced ray shaw
ghoul or the lazarus pits yet so we'll
find out more about that because that
seems like such a critical part of him
becoming red hood in the comics
i've also talked about the batman long
halloween animated movie that they're
going to be releasing next year
there's a lot of new dc animated movies
despite the fact that they rebooted the
dc animated universe with justice league
apocalypse war
so it sounds like some of the new
animated movies will just be doing their
own thing in their own continuities and
then they'll also restart sort of a new
justice league storyline with a new cast
dc animation is usually pretty on point
i'm a big fan of that classic
under the red hood movie so it'll be
interesting to see what this choose your
own adventure style version of this
movie is like
it's coming out in a couple weeks in
october so i'll try to do another video
for it when it actually drops
while you wait for everything click here
to re-watch the batman trailer with
robert pattinson a billion more times
and click here for my brand new black
adam trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!